european union fisheries ministers have
reached agreement on what stocks and how
much fish can be caught next year
by eu vessels in european and other
waters
total allowable catches and fishing
quotas have been set for stocks in the
atlantic
the north sea the baltic and black seas
as well as for international waters
where eu vessels work
the main goal is to avoid overfishing by
managing stocks at maximum sustainable
yields or msy
which is the largest catch that can be
taken from a fish stock
over an indefinite period without
harming it
we have reached three oh 30 stocks
will be fished at msy in 2015.
we have improved our record so for 2014
we are going to bring two stocks more
and for
2015 three more the belief is that
managing stocks according to
maximum sustainable yields will in the
end lead to bigger stocks and a higher
catch
potential recent information published
by the european commission
shows an increase in stocks exploited at
msy levels
and a general decrease in overfishing
the eu's lithuanian presidency said the
catchers and quotas
are in line with the new common
fisheries policy which will come into
force next year
in another major development the council
officially rubber stamped the massive
reform
of the common agricultural policy
kick-starting a new set of measures to
make the cap more competitive and
sustainable
as well as to breathe new life into
europe's rural areas